first reactions to the rise of Skywalker
were mostly positive
but clearly mixed now it's time to dive
into the full-length reviews to see how
critics truly feel about what director
and co-writer JJ Abrams did with the
final installment of the Skywalker saga
warning mild spoilers ahead of the
reviews on Rotten Tomatoes that register
as rotten that is ones accompanied by
ratings below 60% a large portion of
them take issue with the general feeling
of forced wish-granting woven throughout
the film this is to say that many
critics were displeased by the fact that
the rise of skywalker feels like it's
pandering to the audience including
people who were angry with the events of
writer-director Rian Johnson's the last
Jedi a Star Wars installment that
divided fans and caused them to bicker
with critics who praised the film for
the past two years the beginning of
their end destroy it
Michael O'Sullivan of The Washington
Post was one of a number of critics
conflicted over the fanservice crammed
into the rise of Skywalker arguing that
the film panders wildly and concludes
the Skywalker saga quote with the story
that delivers to the faithful exactly
the movie they wanted which may or may
not be a good thing he wrote in his
review everybody wants a happy ending
but that doesn't mean that we should
always get the one we want it's fine if
also cliche to be reminded that good
will triumph over evil but it would make
for a deeper and more powerful lesson
one that after nine movies might leave a
lasting dent in the heart if the hero
actually had to give up something or
someone that didn't feel like a tiniest
bit of a cop-out the film stage critic
Jordan rabe wrote that the rise of
Skywalker is the antithesis to the last
Jedi in that it doesn't take many risks
and undoes a lot of what preceded it he
wrote a direct contradiction to
Johnson's repeated mantra of letting old
things die this ninth and final film in
the series is wholly about the desire to
uncover the past to unlock one's true
identity and honor the generations and
iconic characters that came before by
lacking a sense of vision and embracing
what came before and ignoring the Reese
we laid paths for where this story could
go the rise of Skywalker is not only a
disappointing end to the saga it's also
an ill-fated harbinger for Disney's
future in storytelling other critics
agree with Rob's point that the rise of
Skywalker plays it safe and doesn't take
the risks that it could have decisions
that many feel are to the film's
detriment
USA TODAY's Brian Truitt who gave the
rise of Skywalker two and a half stars
out of four wrote in his review
it's impressively ambitious though great
new personalities and fresh storytelling
suffer for the sake of fanservice some
of the liberties Rian Johnson's last
Jedi took with a nostalgic Star Wars
status quo our rethought here so get
ready for a disturbance in the fandom
over at slate Sam Adams wrote that
Abrams attempted to make a movie no one
would hate instead of one that some
might love resulting in a film that's
only satisfying because it's been
force-fed to viewers he added the haste
with which the rise of Skywalker rushes
to undo its predecessor is almost
comical at first at least before its
capitulation to the franchise's most
toxic fans turns outright contemptible
in other less than great reviews of the
rise of Skywalker a common gripe was
that the film comes across confused and
messy dan Merle of screen junkies said
in his video review there seems to have
been absolutely no roadmap as to what
these movies were going to be and it
shows meanwhile Uproxx senior
entertainment reporter Mike Ryan argued
that the film is perplexing clumsy and
totally overstuffed
writing JJ Abrams Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker is the most convoluted of all
the Star Wars movies it feels like three
full movies worth of plot crammed into
one film the stories in the other Star
Wars movies even the prequels have a way
of bringing a viewer into that world
Star Wars the rise of Skywalker never
lets us in it instead keeps us at arm's
length so it can use almost its entire
first half as exposition just character
after character explaining things Ryan
also felt that the rise of Skywalker
panders to a certain type of Star Wars
fan adding there were times at
like the rise of Skywalker was put
together by reading angry reddit boards
just throwing in anything a fan might
possibly want to see it really is
baffling over at Vanity Fair Richard
loss and expanded on the point Ryan
brought up writing in his review there
doesn't seem to be any real organic idea
animating rise of Skywalker instead it
feels cobbled together from notes
stuffed in the suggestion boxes of
Reddit and Twitter
I don't think rise of Skywalker is
ill-intentioned exactly but it takes no
pleasure in its own existence where
there are detractors there are also
cheerleaders and the rise of Skywalker
has plenty of enthusiastic critics
rallying behind it once who had no
trouble giving the film flawless five
out of five star reviews and praising it
as a satisfying conclusion to the four
decade-long Star Wars story
Jordan Hoffman at the Guardian was one
such critic who stamped the rise of
Skywalker with a perfect rating writing
the movie snaps together like a jigsaw
puzzle a series of concluding beats that
seemed inevitable and perfect and
designed to please all parties so long
as you don't dwell on the logic too much
Newsday's Rayford guzman gave the film
three out of four stars and said that
the main takeaway is that quote after
more than 40 years the Star Wars series
comes in for a smooth landing Richard
Roeper at the Chicago sun-times had even
more kind things to say about the rise
of Skywalker though he ultimately felt
the film was really good but not great
writing the rise of Skywalker is an
action filled plot packed unabashedly
sentimental cameo heavy rousing
adventure the special effects are as
fantastic as you'd expect them to be the
performances are earnest and in some
cases emotionally impactful the rise of
Skywalker rarely comes close to touching
greatness but it's a solid visually
dazzling and warm-hearted victory for
the force of quality filmmaking
someone who did feel the rise of
Skywalker is capital F fantastic was the
Seattle Times Soren Anderson who wrote
in part epic it indeed is full of
magnificent set pieces sprawling space
battles and incandescent lightsaber
duels gripping performances and an
number of truly stunning surprises
Digital spy's e'en Sandwell was
noticeably impressed by the rise of
Skywalker calling it an emotional
thrilling and satisfying in to the
Skywalker saga with plenty of surprises
up its sleeve
he wrote the rise of Skywalker shines
with emotional beats that fans won't
forget as well as crowd-pleasing payoffs
that have been decades in the making
given the task that Abrams faced when he
returned to the franchise Star Wars the
rise of Skywalker is an impressive
achievement it won't please everybody of
course but there will be plenty who find
it ends the Skywalker saga on a high so
it sounds like some people are going to
love the rise of Skywalker and some
people are going to hate the rise of
Skywalker which is no big surprise if
you find yourself in the latter camp
take heart a new episode of the
Mandalorian airs December 27th check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]